I do, I do want to know that as an animator,
are there any like scenes or any animation cuts that you really look up to
and you like idolize is legendary and have inspired you.
Uh, like, uh, uh,
you have a lot of animation of a wobble,
how he make this movement. Right. And so, yeah,
when you doing a frame pal frame on your animator, right?
Watch the movement. Okay. Oh, I just spent, Oh,
this just for me just expose at one, two. Oh,
this frame is of course a tree and all at this moment,
you have the fire come here and there is a movement like that
frame by frame, every animators doing like that. And so, Oh,
so this is the key animation.
Really slow.
She's a journeyman like everybody. Well, what was this moment?
So I put a stop and Felbam from performance.
I guess,
I guess like an animator or I guess like director that comes to mind when it
comes to like amazing animation will be like Satoshi call-in. Right. Like he,
you know, she, she, like, he managed to like animate in a way,
because I think I saw it in some kind of interview with him, like way before,
um, that, like,
the reason why he went into animation was because his way of directing is too
fast for live action. Yeah. So, whereas like,
because there's so many cuts in con movies where it's just,
it's like a blink it's so fast,
it's almost subliminal that you just can't replicate in live action.
And he's just, I don't know, like even I'm not an animator at all or anything,
but like you can watch a Satoshi con movie and be like,
how do you even like think to animate something like that?
I have one of my senpai who had walked on a constitution movie. Uh, it was a,
her the co-director of, uh, Tokyo. Good poser. His name is,
uh [inaudible] and, uh, yeah, you,
the con movies are very realistic, uh, realistic,
but under war funds of character, the expression that
[inaudible]. So we mix up as a picture and [inaudible]
, You can watch it every time and
you have a depression. Oh, Oh, you didn't just get teased
with connect with. And, uh,
and also like a Tokyo godfather, because I don't know
, it's a movie you want to watch it at Christmas? Yeah.
It's one of the few Christmas anime movies.
Not that it was meant to be a Christmas movie. It was just,
it just happens to be Christmas. Right.
And, uh, yeah,
but when my senpai said concert or she was one of the best
maybe best enemy. Oh yeah. It's free.
Or you Erie faster addiction in here have a perfect drawing.
Yeah, because I think, I,
I think I saw that like Satoshi Khan used to like draw some of his own
animations as well, because the key animator.
He's, uh, he had done mangaka he? Yes, he was manga.
He had to walk on a lot of [inaudible]. Yeah. And so, yeah. I don't know. He can
walk on Akira or not. I don't remember. But, uh,
yes, he was very cross with automo, with a dozer generation of artists who was
a lot of movie makers in Japan.
Animator. What do you think of like a Kira for instance, like the animation.
Cura is amazing because I.
Feel that like, when, when people say Akira, they're just like, yeah,
this animation has an age. Like so well even, yeah.
If you want to, if you want a better, uh, for animators,
a good, uh, an emission you have, so, uh, general general,
I've heard, that's pretty lucky for my son back. He said that, uh,
general is to admission, realistic, most push extreme,
too much extreme that most of the animators is just a for musterbation of
animation. It's too much,
but it's a good entertainment one.
And with good animation or so very pushed was, uh, uh,
memories are the ultimate Katsura and you have the
[inaudible] of animation is a master cross because it's a,
most of the frames are, um, explosion or three,
three frame in less frame, but just good drawings, good timings.
And.
I'll stop. You may need a grocery if you don't know is like a space opera arc.
Yeah. That's the only way to describe how old is it?
It's like from the nineties, like late nineties, it was like,
it was quite a while after,
but it's like a magnetic Rose is like a short film that authorize your a
directed 14 minutes. It's like a 40 minute like short film, but it's like, yeah,
it's basically just space. Opera. Opera is the only way to describe it,
but it's amazing.
Is this the same team that managed to cross? You have a [inaudible] run mirrors.
Yeah. I didn't watch it, but I had watched some
[inaudible] very impressive. So, yeah. So.
So I guess if you want to like, stop being animated, just study those, right.
This is the realest ones, the golden age of animators. Will you say that.
It's interesting hearing an actual opinion from an actual animator.
Cause you know, it's, it's because, you know, when, whenever we think of like,
Oh, what do we think is the best animated, whatever of anime of all time.
Like most people would say like red line probably is the one that comes to my
mind.